[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
4 mai cent trente agriculteurs venus de
toute la france réunies à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet 19e édition du
marché pari fermier glaces artisanales
crêpes et produits du terroir nous
parlerons de l'ensemble des animations
avec notre invité des contes histoires
et comptines avec des mots signés pour
apprendre la langue des signes
les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines propose des séances le samedi
objectif découvrir une autre manière de
communiquer enfin notre rendez-vous
junior sera culturelle des
représentations à ne pas manquer pour
les plus jeunes mais annie poker nous
emmènera à la rencontre de titi un
acrobate et de carmen une petite fille
de spectacles à découvrir ce week end
et depuis le 1er mai le petit train à
vapeur du musée rend boli train est
remis sur les rails les voyageurs sont
invités à prendre place à l'arrière du
wagon pour une promenade dans les
jardins autour du musée l'occasion aussi
de redécouvrir cet établissement
consacré aux trains jouets et pourquoi
pas devenir chef de gare le temps de la
visite
et ce week-end le soleil sera au beau
fixe profitez-en pour faire un tour à
versailles 10e édition d'esprit jardin
plus de 25000 visiteurs et 80 exposants
sont attendus au coeur du quartier saint
louis
des visites du potager du roi sont
prévus ainsi que des spectacles théâtre
la projection du documentaire zéro phyto
100% bio et des promenades nature et
sonore un programme en rapport avec la
thématique de cette année la thématique
cette année c'est l'art au jardin
donc nous allons avoir un peu de street
art on va avoir quelques artistes
on va voir on va dire des visites pour
essayer de faire découvrir comment le
jardin bouger comme qu'est ce que c'est
que ce printemps qu'est ce que c'est que
ce printemps en particulier avec le
chaud le froid le chaud le froid et
commence à nous influencent donc on a
clairement deux à trois semaines de
retard mais ça veut dire aussi que nos
asperges sont tendres
que nos faibles sont toutes petites que
nos petits poissons pas encore prêt mais
que nos herbes aromatiques fleurissent
et sont particulièrement engorgés des
huiles essentielles qui leur donne leur
goût
[Musique]
avis aux amateurs du goût et aux
amoureux du terroir vous avez rendez
vous dès ce samedi 5 mai à rambouillet
le marché parie fermiers vous attend un
événement incontournable pour découvrir
le savoir faire artisanal et agricoles
on en parle avec notre invité sur les
images de mélanie poker nous sommes à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet c'est
ici que va se tenir le 19e marché pari
fermier 130 agriculteurs seront là
jusqu'au 8 mai pour vous présenter leurs
produits nous sommes avec coralie bell
responsable de l'association pari
fermier bonjour alors pendant ces
quelques jours c'est vraiment la
gastronomie et le terroir qui sont à
l'honneur les producteurs viennent de
toute la france pour ce rendez vous oui
effectivement vous avez cent trente
agriculteurs des gens qui produisent
élèves et transforme qui viennent et qui
vendent leurs produits en direct et qui
vendent du coup leurs produits aux
consommateurs aux visiteurs et donc ils
viennent là effectivement de toute la
france vous avez des producteurs du pays
basque donc un peu plus de 800 km comme
la ferme elizaldia qui fait du jambon de
bayonne et tous ses produits dérivés
vous avez par exemple aussi scarlette le
corre qui vient du fin fond de la
bretagne avec des produits de la mer
vous avez aussi du vin d'alsace où des
gens qui viennent aussi du dans le gard
avec avec de l'huile d'olive par exemple
donc c'était pour l'aspect salé ya
beaucoup de choses mais pour les becs
plus sucré pour les vrais gourmands
aussi on a on a des choses
oui tout à fait alors on à emilie blanc
par exemple qui fait des glaces à base
de lait de ses vaches et aussi qui fait
qui récolte des fraises
donc elle nous propose un petit panel de
desserts sucrés tout le week-end un vrai
succès vous avez aussi des classes
avec des oeufs d'autruche de d'isabelle
perrette
vous avez aussi des glaces aux
confitures de françoise et robert mas
dryas par exemple ont plein de petites
pâtisseries aussi des biscuits sucrés à
base d'amandes et d'olives de laurence
et jean la guerre qui viennent du gard
voilà plein de petits produits
différents qui peuvent satisfaire les
visiteurs
donc on a vraiment des choses originales
peut-être un coup de coeur sur un ou
deux exposants à nous partager
alors le petit coup de coeur de cette
année je dirais c'est chloé norgay qui
vient donc la ferme de l'étang qui vient
du perche
une jeune agricultrice qui a repris la
ferme de son papa ya pas très longtemps
et qui fait de la viande de cerf et de
sangliers donc et tous les produits
dérivés plats cuisinés viandes fraîches
pâté saucisson et c'est donc voilà on a
tout ce qu'il faut pour se régaler en
tout cas précisons que ces produits
qu'on peut retrouver donc ils sont en
provenance directe des fermes vous
l'avez dit ils ont été transformés par
les exposants eux mêmes
l'idée c'est vraiment de favoriser le
local les petits producteurs
ah oui alors là on est en plein dedans
dans le circuit circuits courts pardon
et vente directe ce qui est vraiment
important pour nous c'est de montrer aux
visiteurs et consommateurs que quand ils
viennent sur un pari fermier
ils ont en face d'eux l'agriculteur qui
donc produit élèves et transforme donc
si je dois prendre un exemple par
exemple un producteur qui vend ses
fromages de chèvre est bel et bien il a
ses chèvres c'est le lait de ces chèvres
et il fait son fromage
donc voilà c'est très important pour
nous que le consommateur comprenne qu en
face d'eux c'est l'agriculteur et les
produits qu'ils consomment
bah c'est bien ça vient bien de la ferme
de l'agriculteur c'est vraiment
authentique vraiment authentique
six circuits courts vente directe y a
pas d'intermédiaire pas de commerces pas
de commerçants pas de revendeurs etc
c'est pareil dans le vin vous n'avez que
des vignerons n'y a pas de négociants
pas de pas de revendeurs c'est vraiment
le vigneron qui en face de vous pour les
jeunes pour les plus jeunes c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir un savoir faire
découvrir ce qu'il ya dans nos assiettes
a aussi que tout simplement et peut-être
discuter sur comment est-ce qu'on
fabrique du fromage comment est ce qu'on
fait du vent oui c'est vrai alors là
j'ai un exemple qui me vient en tête
on a un producteur qui et qui fait des
pommes de terre et qui pendant tout le
week-end fait des frites avec ses pommes
de terre et on a régulièrement la la
stupéfaction des enfants de voir ce
producteur en train de faire ses frites
tout le week-end et certains disent ah
mais c'est comme ça qu'on fait des
frites et voilà cet agriculteur fabien
marois se lève tous les matins vers 4
heures du matin pour préparer seyfried
pour qu'elle soit bien bien prête pour
les visiteurs donc voilà c'est des
petits exemples alors le le poulet
fermier aussi les poules poulets parce
qu'on a un agriculteur etienne godart
par exemple qui fait des poulets rôtis
sur place donc voilà toutes ces petites
choses doivent être naturel en gagne
gastronomie interpelle souvent les
enfants sur le marché on pourra aussi
goûter certains produits une
restauration fermière est prévu tout le
week-end oui alors là il ya pléthore de
plats à consommer sur place
vous avez des burgers fernier avec de la
viande
limousines vous avez des burgers de
bison si vous avez des assiettes de
canard des sandwichs au foie gras des
sandwiches au jambon de l'aligot des
assiettes de fromages voilà il ya plein
de choses diverses et variées proposées
tout le week-end alors comme nous sommes
à la bergerie nationale des animations
qui sont proposées pour rythmer la
journée
oui c'est vrai que le marché ne va pas
sans les animations les gens viennent
pour les deux donc vous avez plein
d'animations tout le week-end des
balades en calèche des balades à dos
d'âne la visite de la ferme sur tout et
tous les animaux donc il ya vraiment de
quoi faire pour passer une vraie journée
entre restauration marché et visites
merci beaucoup coralie belle pour toutes
ces précisions donc alors avis aux
gourmands et aux amoureux du terroir et
de la gastronomie
le 19e marché pari fermier c'est ce week
end jusqu'au 8 mai à rambouillet petits
et grands sont attendus pour se régaler
des histoires racontées avec la langue
des signes dans les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les plus
petits peuvent écouter et voir des
comptes avec le langage des mains une
découverte d'une autre forme de
communication qui peut aider les enfants
à s'exprimer images de nicolas landry
[Musique]
c'est une comptine bien connue des
petits et des grands mais avec quelque
chose en plus le langage des signes
véronique aulas fait découvrir aux
enfants et à leurs parents la langue des
signes française
un autre mode de communication
accessible aux plus jeunes c'est avec
des mots signés issus de la langue des
signes française pour pouvoir
accompagner les mots parlés et enrichir
le lexique de communication va dire pour
l'enfant de façon à ce que l'enfant
puisse aussi
reprendre les signes en terme de
mouvements et de gestuelle pour pouvoir
les utiliser dans son expression
bonjour tout le monde
c'est l'heure de se lever et le maire
l'éléphant multicolores ou boucles d'or
des histoires simples qui permettent aux
enfants de 6 mois à 4 ans de
s'identifier
donc je vais prendre en fait des albums
jeunesse de la vie quotidienne avec le
doute vous avec manger ou boire pour
pouvoir donner du vocabulaire de base et
des signes et de la gestuelle du de la
vie quotidienne prochaine séance prévue
le samedi 5 mai à la médiathèque du
château de plaisir un moment de partage
où les grands apprennent presque autant
que les petits
pour les enfants ce week-end de deux
spectacles
à noter mélanie pour notre rendez-vous
des juniors vous nous emmener à la
rencontre d'autres titres wii et titi
c'est un acrobate ce qui lui plaît lui
ces déséquilibres il aime tellement ça
qu'il en fait avec tout et n'importe
quoi il le fait tout seul mais un jour
il va croiser nana qui est pleine de
fraîcheur de curiosité et de liberté
alors si tu tombes tu tombes pas c'est
une création de la compagnie pascale
rousseau pensée pour le jeune public et
notamment les enfants de 3 à 6 ans
regardez cet extrait de la bande annonce
[Musique]
e
alors où aller pour savoir si titi
petite fille ne va vous attendre à la
lanterne de rambouillet ce samedi deux
séances ont privé sont prévues par la
première à 10h30 et celles à 17h alors
autre lieu autre aventure à coignières
c'est l'histoire de carmen que le public
peut suivre
c'est une histoire libre d'adaptation de
la bd les petits jeux les petites gens
de sens où il a bu beaucoup de théâtres
musicaux
cette part à la rencontre de carmen
c'est une petite fille de 11 ans et elle
vit dans une rue où deux immeubles se
font face carmen elle vient seulement
d'emménager et surtout elle a
interdiction de sortir seule de sortir
seul le sort dans la rue c'est un ordre
de vigie sa maman mais bien sûr la
petite fille est une aventurière
curieuse elle va donc sortir un mardi
soir 1-1 mardi soir où elle va
rencontrer louis le petit garçon aux
beaux yeux bleus au beau jeu triste qui
habite juste en face et c'est parti pour
un spectacle musical extrait derrière
les semaines je voudrais voir des tons
l'air
je voudrais voir des psys ont l'air pour
des pions des étoiles plein les yeux
dans ma rue est à voir dès 6 ans rendez
vous au théâtre alphonse daudet de
coignières samedi 5 mai à 17 heures
merci mélanie news avoir dévoilé la
programmation culturelle de ce week end
pour les plus jeunes et tout de suite
son pass à l'agenda
[Musique]
ce samedi c'est le free comic book day
dans toute la france en événements venu
des états unis arrivé en france depuis
2014 pour faire découvrir ou redécouvrir
les comics les librairies participantes
offre gratuitement des albums édités
spécialement pour l'occasion
à saint quentin en yvelines le pavé du
canal les furet du nord et le culture à
des clefs sous bois participe à
l'opération
n'hésitez pas à vous y rendre pour
profiter et le 7-8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous espérons que vous avez fait
le plein d'idées sorties on se retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end
[Musique]
où